[Music]
identify currency bills with being a I
one of the things that seeing AI can do
is recognize currency bills currently we
only do US dollars this is important
because US currency is all the same size
and even the same color so it's hard to
differentiate what some people will do
then is fold it into different shapes or
put it in different parts of your wallet
but to do that you still need to go
through and identify each of the notes
you can do this with our currency
channel simply place the phone over a
note and here the denomination it's
lunchtime here so let's see how much
money I have here I'm just going to put
the phone over the bill one u.s. dollar
one dollar unfortunately that's not
going to buy much today let's see what
else I have
20 US dollars cool 20 dollars that's
more like it you'll see that this is
quite a nice $20 bill what about if it
was all scrambled up let me do that for
you now let's see it looks a bit older
now so let's see what it's going to say
now 20 US dollars cool so just as fast
it's recognizing and no to it or maybe
not quite so pristine that's currency
for you let's go and get some lunch
Microsoft logo appears